what's going on let's do it we got the
animal print come on let's do it talk
about the tears man it was an emotional
well yeah it was um
I I wasn't expecting to get
um just so choked up my judges pull
yourselves together
like they're crying all over the stand
up here I love this show because I just
cry all the time the only time you
actually cry you know the hometown's
going back and seeing where these kids
come from is pretty special stuff
their Journey from the very beginning
yeah to take them from you know having
no idea that their lives gonna turn into
this and in a short matter of months it
just Superstars obviously yeah I mean
it's it's special and and
really looking back
um
I can't uh I can't find any fault at how
the voting went I felt like um
um but I feel like I feel like there's
so many
um potential stars in that top top 10
and even top five even when I see Haven
Haven Madison up there with Katie you
know she she puts out all the right
Vibes for stardom and and Colin Colin
and Megan do too kind of in the country
realm but then you know em certainly it
just felt like he had the he had the
juice from day one which is which is
great you know I mean I think um he you
know his story was a big reason why so
many people were just so engaged in the
show I mean literally also I feel like
you know he is living out his dream
right but it's all starting today so
what advice do you have for him because
I'm sure he's looking at you thinking I
want a career like Luke Bryan you know
well you know I think the main thing is
um you have to make sure it's all on
your terms and and and really
um when you're when somebody's trying to
push you down a creative path
um that you may not be on you may be
unsure of you know just trust your gut
on stuff and and uh and also understand
that
um you're gonna make some mistakes
and you know I've learned through the
years that you know
if you make a mistake publicly or
whatever your fans will have your back
and be humble and be apologetic and I've
had
uh bad performances and bumps in the
roads and I I owned it and made and you
know it's just this thing's a wild ride
but but you know navigate it navigate it
with your friends and your family and
have fun with it and understand that um
at the end of the day
it's just music and and you're out there
and it's mu well not just music but it's
it's uh you know if you if you find
yourself down some days just you know
just go write a song about it and use
music to get you through I think it
helps that he's also America's
sweetheart so I think we got his back
forever you know well yeah I mean it's
just so lovable and so relatable and you
know and he's just a great Storyteller
with the songs and and then when you
look at his ability to really create
that Island Vibe is pretty pretty
special and it's in his blood
DNA for sure now tonight you're in the
Splash Zone next to Katie I mean were
you having to dry her tears a little bit
hey she was I've never you know she was
emotional all night too and and you know
I think like I said I never anticipated
you know crying on national TV that much
but you know I think we're just
mimicking what people are feeling at
home and and you know I think I think
that's what makes the show really
special is it it we don't Dodge around
uh we don't Dodge around their
backgrounds and their stores and their
paths and their Journeys we actually
probably help them heal a little bit let
them get that story out there and
understand that they're not alone how
can we expect you back at the judges
panel next season well we're working on
it and uh but this has been an amazing
year
[Music]